wow thank you all for being here i
really appreciate it and uh i've got
some great friends over here to my
right that you're gonna hear from words
from in just a few minutes uh i
appreciate you being here
uh this morning or this afternoon rather
uh
i'm glad that i've got so many members
of the private sector tax force with us
today
that are going to be able to shed some
light on what they've done and the
programs that they put in place
as many of you know in march of 2020
none of us knew what toll this pandemic
would take on the world
especially on the state of nevada we
were deeply affected but for all that we
suffered we had a distinct advantage
over other states in tackling our needs
and showing up our resources
our business community and partners that
you see here
in the private sector is an advantage
that nevada has that no one else did and
they really stepped up in a time of need
when i first called jim murray and asked
him for help to chair a private sector
task force
he did not hesitate one minute to hit
the ground running
and he quickly assembled the diverse
group of individuals that you see here
and community leaders
all of whom were just looking for ways
that they could help us
today they will present their report on
their activities since they first formed
that over a year ago in the spirit not
only of transparency but also to
celebrate their tremendous
accomplishment accomplishments
and to express thanks to the hundreds of
members of our community
who stepped up along the way to help us
they gave donations
some as small as five dollars others
as large as a million dollars over a
million dollars
some provided their professional
expertise pro bono
some handed out masks to those in need
some donated laptops to our school kids
so they continued learning while at home
they all found a different niche that
they could help us with and selflessly
they contributed in ways that i can
never
thank them enough for what they did it's
made a tremendous difference in our
fight against covet 19
and i am incredibly grateful that the
work that they did and how they saved
the state of nevada
i'm proud of our state its leaders and
all its residents for showing the power
of public partner pub public-private
partnerships
in the strength and resilience of all
nevadans and i would like to
invite now my friend and the chair of
the task force jim murran up
to say a few words jim
[Applause]
well good afternoon and how good is it
to uh hug somebody
anybody anybody especially the governor
of the great state of nevada thank you
all for
coming here uh it seems like uh so long
ago
that uh we were in a situation that we
could never have imagined finding us
ourselves in uh we were scared
uh we were felt helpless
we felt hopeless we didn't really quite
know
what this pandemic would do and more
importantly we didn't know
how we would survive what we would do
for ourselves and for our families
it's times like this where i'm
incredibly proud
to be in nevada for you see i've been
through
a crisis before actually more than one
and every time we have faced the
challenge as a state
the men and women of our state have
risen to that challenge
whether it was 9 11 or the great
recession
or the horror of one october or most
recently
this pandemic each time
in those dark days we wondered how our
state
would pull itself through how we would
get to the other side and each time
we did so with courage and dignity
and a sense of purpose working together
as the private sector
and the public sector so as with that
confidence
and that experience that i i worked with
the governor
well over a year ago i knew we would get
through this
i didn't know exactly how or when
but i knew we would because we'd done it
before
when the governor said jim
we'd like to get together with a private
sector group
maybe put some men and women together to
find resources
to reach throughout the globe to find
people to help us
in our small state it was a call
that i was honored to take i have to
credit mgm resorts
for allowing me to leave a bit early to
do that
i was going to retire about a year later
than i did
but when this came up i felt strongly
that i could be better served
to do so for the state and mgm
as always in my entire life with it
since i met mr kakorian so many decades
ago
was there to help the state and allow me
to do
what i wanted to do and we assembled
this group of people
these men and women these heroes of
nevada
who gave themselves thanklessly and
tirelessly
and completely to help us get through
this
what did we need right away do you
recall
the fear that we all had we did not have
personal
protective equipment we did not have the
basic equipment to keep our first
responders our medical professionals the
people in the grocery stores the men and
women that were working
on the resort corridor and everywhere in
the valley we did not have
that basic equipment to keep people safe
and how could we get it because a small
state of nevada was up against big
states like california and new york
texas with big budgets they were paying
too much for ppe
they didn't care where they got it they
didn't know if it was going to be
legitimate or not
what was a little state like nevada
going to do in a situation like that
and it was with the courage and the
generosity of the resort community
win resorts mgm resorts
caesars stations
boyd and every single gaming company
along with
nevada energy nevada gold mines and some
every other large employer global
companies
said we can do better we're going to
reach out to china
we're going to reach out to japan to
europe we're going to help you find that
ppe
we're going to help you procure it we're
going to make sure it's legitimate
and safe and authentic we're going to
make sure you don't overpay for it
you're not going to get gouged
we're going to help you get it here i
remember talking to mr adelson
god rest his soul who gave us planes
to go to china to get that ppe back here
now isn't that a legacy of an individual
we raised 12 million dollars
in a week and a half i called up
that's not bad
[Applause]
i called up the people that always given
this state
their names are in this report i said
you've always given before
i hate always going to you for things
like this but when
the call was made they answered the call
and we raised that money why was that
important
because the companies that were making
that pp and said
okay we'll sell it to you but it's money
up front
got to get the money in front and if we
didn't have that money
up front we would not have gotten that
ppe
and we would not have been able to
protect
the tens of thousands of medical
professionals
to hundreds of thousands of first
responders and the men and women of
nevada
then we had a problem with testing we
could not find
an ability to test enough of our people
here
why because so much of the testing
capacity was out of state
do you remember this you'd get a test
it'd be shipped out of state maybe you'd
get it back in five days
which what does that mean it was
worthless
it did not do a thing for you so we
worked with umc
and with renown in the nevada state
health labs
we said what do you need they need
resources they need contacts
we helped build a covet specific lab
at umc that could test not a couple
hundred people a day
but upwards to thousands tens of
thousands of people a week
could have been tested and were tested
because of that
we realized that we had to find a way to
make sure that we could contact trace
people
be able to understand if i have this
disease i want to make sure my loved
ones and anyone around me because i'm a
human and i care about other humans
knows that they need to figure out where
they can get medical treatment
so they call my friend andrew pascal who
was a technology genius
and he brought us covid trace which
as you now know over a million people in
our state
have downloaded and have used in order
to check
their health status i got a call
not long after that from
a woman who needs no introduction in
nevada who has been there for decades
and of course i'm talking about elaine
nguyen
and she said jim we have a problem
so many of our students here in the
state
do not have access to the internet how
can we
teach our young boys and girls
if they cannot even get online and how
do we reach them
how do we know where they are in the
poor rural
urban communities in the rural
communities how can we find them
and so with puna mather who i see over
here
and with our superintendent and with
every one of the public education
foundation
we got together and we reached out
and we connected the entire state of
nevada
every single county in this state
in a matter of months so that no child
was disadvantaged by something they had
no
no call over of course the pandemic
and the list goes on and on people
donating dollars
tens of dollars millions of dollars
people reaching out and said you know
what
i have a cosmetics company i think i can
make hand sanitizer
i live in the state you coached my kid
in little league
i want to help you jim and merle norman
uh travis richards who lives here in
town
said i think i can do it he gave us
gallon after gallon hand sanitizer that
we gave away
do you remember trying to find masks
trying to find a mask
that you could just go to the store and
feel good about
governor said we need more mass jim and
so i reached out to a handful of men and
women in our community
including steve klubeck who has been so
philanthropic in the past
we bought hundreds of thousands of
nevada state masks and it was so
incredibly heartwarming to see our
governor
and medical profi providers and athletes
and performers
wearing those very masks
it's been a journey over the past year
plus
but it has been inspiring to me as
someone who loves this state
i couldn't think of a better thing to do
with my time over the past year and a
half
and i want to particularly thank my task
force members
some of whom are here today uh many of
them
could not be here but have send their
love and support and they're all
very appropriately indicated in this
report but i see scott nielsen here
who i love and what you have done with
all the professional services
that have donated so much of their
in-kind work for us scott you
shepherded all that i want to thank you
dearly for that on behalf of the nevada
state of nevada
dr rob macbeth who has been our medical
north star since we began the task force
who i'm going to ask to speak to in a
moment i see
my dear friend alex dixon who has been
basically the chief operating officer of
this task force
who's kept the the wheels on the track
has kept us all working so hard
uh and uh as a great loss to our state
is going to be leaving the state of
nevada for a job outside of the state
boo for for that but we're happy for you
and your family alex
and all the men and women that have
helped us
i thought i'd bring up briefly dr
macbeth
just so we can go back in time
and remember where we were not to scare
us
but to maybe send a message
and this would be my party message to
you
we can never again in my opinion
find ourselves in the position we found
ourselves in
in early twenty twenty we can no longer
be dependent
on states out of this state for our very
safety in our livelihood we cannot rely
on out of state medical providers
testing companies
manufacturers academic institutions
in order to give us the vital tools that
we need
we're the battle-born state for god's
sakes we're an independent state
we need to do this here at home because
make no mistake
there'll be another crisis i've lived
through five
there'll be five more before i leave
this earth
we cannot find ourselves in the position
we found ourselves in
in early 2020 and we can do that
we've done it before and we are going to
do it
now with the efforts of this state to
diversify our economy
to bring businesses into our state to
diversify
the men and women's jobs and be more
self-reliant
which is what nevadans always want to be
and have been so with that i'm going to
bring over dr macbeth if you can come
over
for a moment and please share with your
thoughts
thank you jim and thank you governor um
just incredibly proud not only to serve
on this task force but of
all of the task force members and the
work that they have done
over the last year and a half and all of
the supporting people
that supported the task force which are
too numerous to count but
just a an ongoing incredible effort
looking back in the early days of march
and april of last year
as jim said there was true fear uh
in our community and it it extended
also to our health care providers and
first responders
they were faced with the challenge of
having to go in and take care
of very sick people but without
effective or enough personal protective
equipment
and so incredibly grateful for the
donors
and coming up with the funding to allow
us to leverage the contacts that
that our gaming industry and and jim's
team had across the globe to secure the
ppe
which was so critically important for
our health care workforce and first
responders to continue to do their jobs
uh in in a safe manner it was a it made
a critical difference and
and uh very proud of that effort and and
a
just an enormous debt of gratitude and
thank you
from all of the health care providers in
this community and first responders
uh for that effort speaking to the
to the testing jim is spot on
we had no real capacity
to address this pandemic and
the the capability that we did have
while the laboratories were local these
tests were done
out of state and the turnaround times
were five days would be good
uh it was often much longer than that
and that had a critical impact on just
about every facet
of the work that we were doing in the
healthcare
sector and when we look at establishing
the ability to do our own testing at umc
that was an absolute game changer
it affected patients patients who still
needed to have surgery still needed to
have procedures done
we're able now to be tested with
turnaround times as less
as low as six hours it was it was a
phenomenal
change in the way we could actually care
for people
safely in the community so my message
uh to uh everyone is just
that about a large debt of gratitude for
everybody's participation
uh in helping us accomplish these goals
so thank you all very much
good afternoon everyone my name is alex
dixon i humbly serve
as a finance chair for the task force
and first let me uh
thank uh jim uh for what an honor it's
been to serve
it's uh been an absolute pleasure i'm
born and raised here third generation
and uh
to be able to have an opportunity to
serve the state uh has been just
tremendous uh mr governor it has been a
tremendous honor to work with your staff
i've known your chief of staff michelle
white for many years and
she alongside everyone who serves in
your cabinet and in your agencies has
been tremendously helpful
we could not have done it without them
um one of the first calls that i
made very early on was the sandra
douglas morgan who was uh the chair of
the game and control board
and i said sandra the gym said we need a
place in order for four million dollars
for ppe out of china
on tuesday well we had our first call on
saturday
uh and we did not have a dollar raised
at that point because we were still
within the week and a half
and uh i said i'm just a poor boy from
the west side i don't know what uh
how we're gonna figure this out but uh
but we did
and we did it with the help of the
nevada community foundation we did it
with the help of brownstein
we did it with the help of rnr partners
doug cannon who is the ceo of nv energy
you can imagine having a big job like
everybody on this task force
does but put together a procurement
program that was absolutely tremendous
later on we began to to work with many
others within the community
too many to name but the business
information network we're joined here by
long-time city manager betsy
fretwell who has been not only a friend
but has been tremendous throughout this
effort but
none of this could be possible without
our friends at r and r partners
they are a true statewide treasure
and we are grateful for the effort of
catherine cole who not only sits on a
task force with us
but really helps to lead this effort
today and so in short we ran this
like a business we ran it uh with the
board with robin's rooster order
uh with my fellow staff member uh scott
nielsen who's here today
really helped us put in place a
structure to make sure that from a
governance
standpoint uh we could produce what we
did today um and phil satcher who's not
with us today
but helped to lead our audit committee
ensured that we had the support
required to account for the revenues
that came in
we're able to demonstrate how those were
spent we're able to
let our donors know who in the middle of
the night
in many cases answered a call to give
to an organization that they didn't know
about that didn't quite know exactly
what it was going to be
but they believed in us and we're fellow
nevadans and we represent
uh the state and so to be able to have
that opportunity
to be able to deliver and come out on
the other side and see
our hotels uh active to see our
restaurants active
to see people getting back to work to
see people
really being able to have a good
understanding of what it means to be las
vegas
is uh truly a pleasure and it wouldn't
have been possible
with our without our front line health
care responders
and first and foremost that is what we
were here
to set up to do is to protect them so
that they could protect us
and so on behalf of the task force on
behalf of the many volunteers
i thank you i thank you mr governor i
thank you jim for the opportunity to
serve
and my fellow task marks for members
thank you all appreciate it
and to conclude i'd love to if i may
invite the governor up
to officially give you our report um
governor uh this was a labor of love
a love of the state a love of the fellow
nevadans that you represent i'm
incredibly proud to be your friend
you have served our state so incredibly
well
as the ceo of nevada and
thank you for entrusting with us the
responsibility to do what we could
to help you and as always
i'm always going to answer your call for
whatever you need
because i love the state and i love what
you're doing in the states so thank you
very much governor thank you
thank you thank you
[Applause]
uh thank you jim alex rob everybody that
spoke and
words can't express my thanks to these
individuals here
uh i'm surprised jim's going to continue
to answer my calls because every time i
call him i'm asking for help
but he always answers and i really
really appreciate that
and when you look back on this uh what
we went through
i remember the calls i made a gym and
said we need more masks
and the feeling when those planes landed
mccarran and provided masks
provided the ppe for our frontline
workers that was so desperately needed
it was unbelievable and every governor i
was on governor calls every single day
was fighting for the same thing it was a
dollar for mass this one did two dollars
this was 350.
six dollars i mean prices were spinning
out of control
they didn't have a task force like i did
and i'm so
eternally and forever grateful for that
all of you that participated in this and
stepped up
in such an incredible way at every level
whether it was providing tablets
uh broadband access for our rural
communities for our tribal nations for
our students making sure that kids had
an opportunity
making sure that our frontline workers
were taken care of with ppe making sure
that there was food
delivered to folks we faced issues that
this task force with the help of the
nevada national guard
we could never have imagined uh getting
through it without their help and i
sincerely appreciate it
uh we are forever grateful and we're
forever
better as a state as a result of
everything that you all did for us
before i end uh i want to add one more
thing here
uh to remind folks that we've made great
progress with the help of these
individuals from the task force that you
see here
in fighting this pandemic but uh we're
nowhere near done
we're nowhere near done this morning i
read the weekly nevada hospital report
which uh noticed a modest increase i'm
sure you're all well aware of this
in the hospitalizations due to covet 19.
according to the report the commonality
of these hospitalizations is one thing
none of those people were vaccinated
increase in hospitalizations
none of the people were vaccinated we
can prevent the hospitalizations
and we can certainly prevent the deaths
if we just get more people
vaccinated and i beseech my
friends our residents to go
get the shot if you haven't got it yet
if not for yourself
it for your family we know that the last
year and a half the effects of this
virus have not changed
but our tools for fighting the virus
have changed we have vaccines
they're highly effective at reducing the
severity of this
of the cases the hospitalizations and
ultimately deaths
we started with protocols for social
distancing and masks
and hand sanitizer we now have the most
effective tool ever
which is vaccines we need to do more our
health care workers have been on the
front line fighting this virus and this
pandemic
since day one since day one they showed
up for work
when everyone else was didn't know what
to do when we didn't know what to do
they showed up for work and had to use
masks over and over because we didn't
have enough
till these generous folks not only did
they step up and help they stepped up
and wrote checks
let me tell you something state didn't
have 12 you know 5 million 12 million
dollars to go out and buy things
we didn't have my kind of money and the
state never pays up front just so you
know we just don't
we just don't we just don't do business
that way
uh so it would have made impossible for
us to to go this far
last week you all know we announced vax
nevada days our state's incentive
program
and i want to encourage everyone to go
get vaccinated you've got a chance to
win a million dollars you've got a
chance to win a
college scholarship if you're a student
uh
great opportunity there and more
importantly than even the cash prizes
and
and the awards are you're going to
protect your health and the life of all
nevadans
so thank you for being here we have time
for some questions
and i want to conclude with you're my
heroes
thank you thank you
[Applause]
um
well we have and you're welcome to ask
questions of any of these folks if you
want to call them up there and take me
off the hot seat but i'm happy to answer
that question
uh obviously the state relinquished
control to the counties in terms of
vaccinations and this stuff
we are concerned uh we're working as
closely as we possibly can with our
cities and our counties
to make sure that they have the
resources necessary to provide vaccines
whether those are in mass sites or drive
up sites or pop-up sites
whatever it might be we're working with
all of the various counties
to provide whatever resources they need
in order to vaccinate the
the folks that live in the particular
county so we will continue to work with
them
and be available to assist in any way
possible
mary for the next question thank you um
governor is the work of the task force
ongoing
or is it disbanding if it is ongoing
what is the
current priority no this this report
kind of wraps up what they did and it
and i want to say that
if you have a chance to look at it the
transparency that you're going to see
here is something that we need more of
at all levels of government
and all levels of public uh private
partnerships i mean everything is
available here
they uh accomplished you know what we
asked for in terms of
uh procuring the things that we asked
for i mean uh
i didn't ask them to find toilet paper
but i probably should have at that time
uh but their mission that we put them to
is completed
any other questions or members of the
task force
is it john and then channel
okay governor what is your confidence
level that
all the
yeah there are some rural counties that
have been a little more hesitant a
little more resistant
uh we have tried to work with all 17
counties to explain to them to provide
resources that we have
some of them are much more resistant and
hesitant than others
uh we're not forcing anyone to get a
vaccine
like i said we've turned it over to the
various county counties some have been
more aggressive
than others but we will maintain i
maintain that we provide any resource or
tools that we have to assist them and i
think the
best thing that you saw in the hospital
report and i can't stress this enough
the uptick in cases the uptick in
hospitalizations
none of those folks have been vaccinated
i mean if you want to protect yourself
there's a simple solution it's go get
vaccinated
and i encourage everyone to do that
that was it for them
it's good to have great friends i
learned that it's it's uh
i i learned that this community this
state is the most giving
resilient community that you're ever
going to find i challenge any governor
and i've met every governor in the
country any governor to come up with a
group of individuals like this
it's not going to happen it's just not
going to happen you're not going to have
people that just
these are folks that live in nevada
these are folks that love nevada
they love this state like i love this
state and i learned that
we are a resilient state we can come
back
and we will come back we're coming back
better and stronger than ever before
and i learned that you can't be afraid
to ask for help i asked for help and
i mean they delivered better than they
could ever imagined
yet vaccination rates have gone up
no it's a little too early you know i've
asked that same question i'm eager i
hear anecdotal stories that people tell
me or
i frankly hear a lot of stories from my
kids who tell me that their friends
wouldn't got vaccinated because they see
cash at the end of the rainbow
uh so i'm hearing anecdotal stories
it'll be time a little time to tell
if the numbers are increasing as a
result but every shot that we get in
arms
every day that goes by uh we're doing
more to protect our state and protect
our residents and
and i'm thankful for that we'll
i don't know if anybody has i do not
have data as it relates to job
occupations we have as it relates to the
counties but not as the job
job occupations i know a lot of folks in
the resort industry
have given me their figures and uh when
we needed to open up more
we encourage them to get their folks
vaccinated i can tell you i toured an
awful lot of resort hotel sites casino
sites that had vaccination centers
on site to help people get vaccinated i
don't know if anybody has any specific
data as it relates to that don't
and see what they can work that kind of
information is self-reported when you
get your vaccine so
we can um follow up on that mary do you
want to take us from the last question
yeah thank you
um can you clarify what the role of the
task force
was in building umc's testing lab and
increasing its testing capacity
how did the task force's assist well i'm
going to bring marsha turner up here
you drew the short straw marshall sorry
i help on that please you certainly can
yes yeah um
so uh marcia didn't expect to be called
but so mary thank you for doing that so
uh but i saw her in the background and i
wanted to
the the former chief operating officer
of umc so i think uh
you would be the best position to be
able to tell us exactly what happened
right marcia
are you okay with it or not yeah okay
all right
um so i used to serve as the chief
administrator oops i used to serve as a
chief administrative officer for
university medical center
and you know when something like this
happens it's all hands on deck
and i had the good fortune to get a
phone call from
jim murran who asked if the task
force could help umc in developing local
reliable sufficient testing so that
we had enough testing capacity to not
have to be sending the tests out of
state and have those long delays
that you know while you're waiting for a
test result you could potentially be
infecting a lot of people
so with the help of jim and the task
force
they helped umc secure equipment
and supplies to be able to go from
it was the end of april in 2020 when jim
called
umc had the capacity to do 100 tests a
day
and in the months following that they
developed a
separate dedicated covid testing lab
that had i think it was up to ten
thousand test today capacity
and i don't know what the final numbers
are but it is worth looking
at to see how many people were tested as
a result
of mason van gaaling the ceo of umc's
commitment
the help of the governor richard whitley
the people at the state health lab
jim in the task force we were able to
develop
that local reliable testing and then
when the economy was reopening
we had special partnerships with the
different corporations to help them do
the ramp up testing
so that they could have their employees
return to work safely hopefully that
helps
and i want to add to that at the
beginning with the testing
and they're really under it playing
understanding what they did
we didn't have test tubes we didn't have
swabs
we didn't have the transfer agent that
swab had to go into
we didn't have any of that they had to
go find all of this
for us and then we had to assemble it in
order to do tests
i mean so much has happened since we
first began here now you can get tests
readily available
they weren't at the moment now you can
buy masks at walgreens or cvs
you i mean we had people donating we had
construction companies and nail salons
donating six masks 12 masks because they
had extras
and that's what we were using for nurses
and doctors
is what this community stepped up and
donated it was a remarkable effort
and it's something that people need to
recognize and the other thing
you need to recognize these spaces and
these names
uh it's words can't express
how incredible they were they answered
every call they answered every challenge
and uh like i said they saved an awful
lot of lives
a lot of lives at the very beginning i
had this discussion with my chief of
staff
we were worried about legitimately
having enough body bags in the state of
nevada
we worried about having body bags we
worried about
crematoriums and air quality how bad it
could get here when they were predicting
30 40 50 000 deaths in the state of
nevada
and who did i call for help the task
force and they were there
so we we made it this far we're going to
make it the rest of the way through this
pandemic
thank you everyone for coming out we
have some printed copies of the task
force report
i will send a press release once they
get back upstairs that has a link
so you can see it online and thanks for
coming out today